Hey, guys. It is time to take a look at the stories
making headlines today and weigh the good with the bad.
It's time for "Pros and Cons." Here we go.
-♪ Pros and Cons and Pros and Cons and Pros ♪
-Tonight we'll be taking a look at the pros and cons
of springtime in New York.
I love New York,
but it's especially beautiful in the spring.
Let's take a look at the pros and cons
of springtime in New York.
Here we go. Pro...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"That's where it was."
It's a rare Duane Reade bird.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
He can pull it off. Yeah. -Come on.
"Yeah. Like this? I got it at Spiffany's."
-Yeah.
It's like, "Uh, it's raining. Just -- Yeah, how much?
Whatever, whatever." Sproing!
Oh, there you go.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And lastly...
That's the "Pros and Cons," everybody.
Thank you very much. Springtime in New York.